Welcome to Episode 34 of the Jordan B
Peterson podcast. I'm Michaela Jordans
daughter. This is an actual interview
podcast. The podcast is also available
in video form on my YouTube channel.
So if you want to see the video form,
it's at youtube.com slash Michaela
Peterson videos, or
you can search Michaela
Peterson Jordan Peterson Coleman Hughes
into YouTube. I'll explain why. This is
technically dad on my podcast, I thought
if I set up the whole podcast and dad
could just walk in and do it, it would
be easier for him. So we ended up doing
it together. We interviewed Mr. Coleman
Hughes, a young extremely intelligent
man that dad will introduce when the
podcast starts. I was so happy to see him
able to work that it really ended up
being more my dad's podcast than mine.
It's probably 90% ham and of course
Coleman speaking. As
you know, Dad has been
incredibly ill with something terrible
called akinesia and hasn't been able
to work much not like this for almost
two years. So this was an absolute thrill
to do and I hope you enjoy it as much
as I did. Next week's episode features
Wim Hof. Please remember to subscribe
rate and share if you enjoy this episode.
Special thanks to our sponsor for
this episode helix without these guys we
wouldn't have the podcast so I really
appreciate them but also listened to this
ad intro I'm pretty one of a kind right?
I'm unique. Well he looks sleep makes
mattresses made for how unique we all
are and how we all sleep differently. I
think that's funny.
Anyway, more seriously,
he looks has the most comfortable
mattress I've ever tried. I used to
have arthritis which I've managed to put
into remission with my carnivorous
lion diet, but it made sleeping incredibly
painful. So I'm pretty picky about
mattresses still. helix sleep has a quiz
that takes about two minutes and matches
your body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you. They're
rated the number one mattress by GQ
and wired. And cnn called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on. And you know how trustworthy cnn
is. I'm the worst at this. I do love my
mattress though. He looks mattresses also
have a 10 year warranty are made right
in America and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free. They'll even
pick it up for you for free if you don't
love it, but you will. Right now helix
is offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders at helix sleep calm slash
Jordan. Get up to $200 off at helix sleep
calm slash Jordan. Enjoy this episode.
Hi there, everyone. We're
privileged tonight to have as a guest,
Mr. Coleman Hughes, who is
one of the most promising young
intellectuals on the American
scene. I met him a couple of years
ago at a function I think it was
in New York, although it might
have been in Washington was in
New York. It was in New York where
I heard him speak as well and
was extraordinarily impressed.
And so we're going to talk to
him tonight about his ideas and
Coleman, it's great to see you.
Let us know what you're up to.
Great to be seen. I'm
here in New York hunkering
down during the sort of
second quasi lockdown that
we're experiencing, I am
happy at work on my first
book, which I just
finalized the contract for.
And working on my own
podcast. We've released 15
or 20 episodes so far
called conversations with
Coleman. And I am
enjoying all of the work that
I'm doing and very happy
to be speaking with you.
Do you want to say a
few words about your book.
The book is a defense of
colorblindness colorblindness with respect
to race, the notion that we
should strive to treat people without
regard to race and eliminate racial
categories as a criteria on which
to base public policy. It's something
that is enormously unpopular in
elite circles, but still enjoys
widespread support in the public,
in the general public. So I'm trying
to make the best defense of the
colorblind ideal that I possibly
can, because I think it's enormously
important principle, to defend
and to have the language to defend.
So if you if you made a case for
the people who hold the country
position, that that race for
example, Perhaps ethnicity or even
cultural background, might instead
be regarded as category of critical
importance. How would they
justify their particular perspective?
I think you could justify the opposing
perspective in a number of different
ways. I would say the strongest
would be to appeal to critique the notion
that
that racism is merely a psychological
phenomenon in the minds of
individuals, a deviation from rational
and objective treatment, because of
somebody's skin color, you can
make the case that because of the
circumstances of American history,
slavery, Jim Crow, redlining, convict
leasing all of the ways in which black
Americans were subjugated, given
that particular history, it makes
sense for black Americans to form
a group consciousness and to
practice group based politics. And that
you can't abstract away from the
circumstances of that history and
do individual to their individual status.
That's right.
Yeah. Well, it's a tricky one, isn't it?
Because race, at least some forms of race,
racial distinctions are pretty obvious.
perceptually. And so
to talk about eliminating
their use as a cognitive category, let's
say our conceptual
category seems what would
you say problematic,
at least in some, in some
regards, right. It's
some effort to become
colorblind. And the argument that because
of history, race, mice might be used, at
least in some
circumstances as a factor for
promotion of, let's
say, affirmative action
policies. It certainly
struck many people as
a powerful argument.
So what do you do you
in your book, you're
obviously going to take
this argument on despite
its its power? Hmm.
Yes. So the very first
thing I plan to do in the
book is clarify what I don't
mean by the admittedly
misleading word,
colorblind. colorblind is a word
like warm hearted. When
you describe someone as warm
hearted, you're not
literally talking about the
temperature of their blood
pumping Oregon, you're speaking
about the kindness of
their spirit. Likewise, with
colorblind it's a it's a word
that employs a physical
metaphor of not being
able to see color, to name an
underlying principle,
which is to strive to treat
people without regard to
their race, and to try and
race neutral public policy.
The The, the notion that
we could ever completely
get to a place where we
are truly colorblind, which
is to say you almost in
the literal sense, you you,
you basically don't even
notice people's color is
naive and utopian. But,
but it seems it's funny, too,
though, you know, to argue the
other side for a moment is
that it doesn't seem logical in
many circumstances to use
race as a criteria for judgment,
because race, per se has
little or nothing to do with, let's
say, desired outcomes for
the task at hand, if you're doing
something like hiring, or, or if
you're engaged in any activity
with someone else that has
an end in mind, you should judge
the people with whom that
pursuit is going to be undertaken
on criteria that have something
to do with their ability to
manage the pursuit. Yeah,
so it seems purely logical to in
some sense to be race blind.
I mean, that's the argument
that people make when when
stating that prejudice is its own
punishment, because you
lose if you're prejudiced against
women, for example, if you're
prejudiced against someone from a
different racial background,
then you lose the ability to hire
them, let's say and therefore,
decrease your pool of talent.
Yeah, that's that's Gary
Becker's The Economist
famous theory of discrimination
and there's certainly
something to be to be
set for that. I just, I just
read an NPR interview with
a public health official who
was talking about the
coronavirus vaccine, and how
they plan to triage the
vaccine. Once it's available,
who's going to get the
vaccine first, second, and third.
And the what this person
laid out made total sense
it was the people with
no conditions. comorbid
comorbidities and the elderly
would get it first. And then
people like me, perfectly
healthy 24 year olds would
be last in line. And then
the NPR interview asked
them, given the fact that
communities of color are
disproportionately affected,
do you you know, it was
pressing her this for this
person to inject race as a
category or criterion among
the risk factors. And you
can you can hear in the
interview, the public health
official getting a little
bit nervous and dancing
around the issue a little
bit. But saying not in so
many words, we're just
going to look at the risk factors
themselves. And
inevitably, if black people are
disproportionately having
comorbidities or having risk
factors, then are, our
race neutral system will
inevitably favor them as
as a side effect, but we don't
need to use race as a as
a proxy, because it's such
a poor proxy for any
given thing in this world that
you could care about
whether that is getting the best
sound editor for your
podcast, or whether it's, you
know, vaccinating the
highest risk populations first.
So many of the arguments
I make in the book are
arguments to stop using
race as a an imperfect proxy for
things like socio economics,
public health and merit.
Hmm, why did you decide to
take this on? You know, I mean, it's
obviously not something that's
going to make you particularly
popular. And I think you have
a history of taking on topics
of that sort. I mean, what's
what's driving you to do this?
Well, I think, um, I think
there is, there is something
slowly slipping away from
us as a culture that's worth
holding on to. And I feel
that from roughly ages zero to
16, I was living about as
colorblind a life as one could. I
effortlessly had white
friends, black friends, Hispanic
friends and Asian friends. I
didn't think of race as anything
more than something to
occasionally make a joke about. And
when, you know, on the rare
instances where I did encounter
racism, I felt something
closer to pity than anger for the
racist, the small minded
bigot, it was obvious to me and
everyone I knew why racism
was evil. I grew up feeling
goosebumps watching Martin
Luther King's I Have a Dream speech
as many people do. But around
the time I was 16, which would
be 2012, I started to get a
download of an entire entirely
different kind of anti
racist ideology that explicitly
rejected aspirational
colorblindness, which told me that, by
definition, as a black
person, I was a victim of white
supremacy, which encouraged
me to focus on on any way, no matter
how minuscule in which I had
been made a victim of white
supremacy. And it seemed to
me that this was not something
that was encouraging a
closer collaboration and closer
intimacy between people of
different races, but was in fact,
creating neuroticism and
paranoia around people of different
races. Now, there's a there's
a an expectation, oh, you
know, as I'm talking to this
person, is this a person who's
gonna assume that I, I'm
worried about microaggressions all
the time, and therefore keep
their guard up? Or in the reverse?
Is this a person who is you
know, highly self conscious
of, quote unquote, white
privilege, and now it just like
it creates a space of nerves
and anxiety around race and
dishonesty, that I found was
not in any way shape or form
fighting racism. But was was
making people racially neurotic.
Do you think that the effects
of, of that highlighting of of
race as a defining characteristic
has particularly pernicious
effects in like the white community
or the black community or
do you think that it's equally
pernicious across communities?
That's a good question.
I suppose it affects folks
in different ways. I know
For for White. for white
people, there's a I think
there's a dividing line
between white people who
feel what is often called white
guilt. And those who don't.
And I think Shelby Steele's
point is worth reiterating,
which is that white
guilt is really misnamed.
It's not really guilt, it's
a terror at the notion that
you might be racist, that
you might be part of the
problem. That and that you
might be seen by others
as racist. It's a it's a deep
terror. And I think those
white people who do feel
that often end up doing
strange and unhealthy things
in order to relieve that
feeling of terror. They
often end up you know,
debasing themselves and playing
the the masochist, or
turning off the skeptical portion
of their brain at any claim
a black person makes.
Right and there's a real
debasing of the conversation.
Hmm, yeah, that's a
terrible, that's a terrible,
that's a terrible thing
to do to an interaction, to
make it so that real
communication can't take place.
Yep. And and on the other
side, with black people, what it
encourages us to do is to,
to hone in on everything that's
to blame the world in society,
for everything that has gone
wrong in our lives, which is
it, it encourages us to get a
sense of meaning and identity
out of the notion that we are
victims, that the that society
is arrayed against us that we
are part part of a noble struggle
against us against a society
that is fundamentally hostile
to people who look like us,
too. You can you can see
what a pervasive problem it is a
because last five or six minutes
of this conversation, both you
and I automatically assumed
that there would be something in
common about what the idea of
race as a core category does to
white people, and perhaps
something different about what it
does to black people. You
know, I'm just bringing that up to
show how tricky it is to manage
the notion of colorblindness
given given the perceptual
presence of racial differences. So
I often find for what it's
worth, that children tend to
understand color blindness
intuitively much more easily
than adults do. They
understand how, how skin color
is, you know, skin deep, it
doesn't mean anything more
than than you make it mean.
And so I often feel that we
are Miss educating our
children or reiterating and re
reifying our own racial
neuroses and perpetrating them
on the next generation,
generation after generation.
I was gonna say growing up in
Toronto was pretty multicultural.
And I didn't like my best
friends were guess half
black, I didn't notice. And
like, unlike you, I grew up
having friends that were you
know, Asian, black, whatever.
And I don't think I noticed
anything until I think I'm a
little bit older than you. So I
think it started in university,
when people started talking
about race more. But what I
really didn't notice,
especially when I was like little
No, it was one of the
delightful things about
being in Toronto was
that, that that ideal of
race blindness? Yeah,
it was really yeah, had
really been achieved. I
would say in many regards.
When I when I went to Montreal, actually.
And there were more Middle Eastern
people. And there were less black
people, I actually noticed that there was
like something missing kind of there
when I moved to Montreal, but growing
up in Toronto, was pretty good for
that kind of thing. But it does seem more
recent. And I do agree that it's not good
for people. It's made me uncomfortable
about who I'm talking to, not based
on their skin color, but based on
what they think about skin color,
whether or not I'm going to be blamed for
something, or whether or not there's
already some animosity between us. And
that's exactly the kind
of neurosis that I'm
speaking of. And I think, particularly in
the past six months with the explosion of
social justice In anti
racism as a result of the
death of George Floyd,
in police custody and
the protests and riots
that ensued, there's a
whole, you know, the
whole underbelly of, you
know, broken friendships
and, you know, brand
new neuroses that people
have developed as a
result of seeing politics,
political demands
that cleave the world into good and evil,
important into into their
Instagram feed every
day, and and essentially
been asked to pick
aside in a very
simplistic caricature of the
problem, and made
to feel evil if they have
any kind of, you know,
skepticism about it.
So that problem that you described,
I mean, I was reading some of the
things that you wrote a couple of
years ago today and including your
review of some of Thomas souls
work the the economist and you talked
about inequality essentially, like
it seems to me that what drives the
continual discussion of race,
particularly in the United States, because
it's less intense here in Canada,
is pervasive inequality. Particularly
inequality between let's say,
the Caucasian majority, although I
don't believe it's a majority
anymore, it's still close to a majority
and the and the black minority.
The fact that that inequality continues
to exist, seems to be the
motivating factor for the supposition
that racial prejudice is still alive and
well. But you review documentation,
and I think this was from soul
as well, that showed that black
immigrants to the United States
weren't characterized by the same
levels of the same levels of
inequality did not obtain between black
immigrants to the United States
and Caucasians who were native to the
US so to speak, it was only a case
for blacks who were born in the US.
Yes, that's correct.
Okay. So that's it,
that's a real that's really
troublesome in about
five different directions.
It's troublesome because
the fact of the inequality
drives the presupposition
that racism still
exists. But the fact that
the inequality doesn't
seem to exist in the
case of immigrants, casts
doubt on the claim
that it is, in fact, racism
that's producing the
inequality. And then you're left
with a question, which
is the question I wanted
to pose to you. You know,
you talked about, you've
written about cultural
differences. Do you think
that there are cultural
differences among the
black community in the
United States? That is
driving inequality forward?
Is it? I mean, I think
that's even a more what
would you call incendiary
topic than the ones that
we've been discussing? Hmm.
Yes, it is an incendiary
topic. But it's also very
plausibly true. And it's,
I think people are very
terrified of this topic.
And they really shouldn't
be. They have a notion
that a if if there are,
if cultural differences
and differences in
behavior patterns, at the
median or at the mean, in
different populations, is
the driving force behind
unequal outcomes, then
that means we can't possibly
fix it. Whereas if it's
systemic racism, then
that's something we can
fix. I think that's a that's
probably a large
exaggeration on both counts.
I, again, I'm not I'm not
necessarily the person
that is going to lead a
movement to to fix behavioral
behavioral patterns, for
example, how how many
hours the average black
student studies per night
compared to how many
average hours the average
white student or or Asian
student studies because
there's also a large
gap on that on that score
between whites and Asians.
But I do think that local
community groups can
make a difference in those
areas. Not only that, I
think it's I think there's
an unreflective assumption
that systemic fixing
systemic racism and
to give an example or or
whether we want to call
this systemic as a separate
question, but fixing a
phenomenon of racial bias
widespread throughout
an injured industry, such as
real estate agents treating
black homeowners different
than they than they do
white homeowners. That's
I'm not sure that's so
easy to fix or any easier
to fix. Then a cultural
problem because they both
involve changing the
behavior of people in private
moments when they may
not have an incentive to.
Well, that's a big danger
between reflexively assuming
that prejudice is that the
is the fundamental cause
of the inequality that
that that is driving the, the,
the debate. The fact of
that inequality is that is
tragic. And it's not going
to be remediated or repaired
until we actually get the
causal story correct. And
what that would mean, if
you are a good social scientist
investigating this is that
you would look at a whole
array of potentially causal
factors, in an attempt
to specify exactly what
it is that is contributing,
you'd probably find that
there were multiple factors,
you know, and hopefully,
they would be small enough so
that some of them could
be remediated. There's some
reason that, that black
immigrants to the US do better.
Hmm, there's something
going on there. I don't know
what it is. I don't know
the literature well enough.
I want to propose a reason
why I don't think inequality
is as tragic as it seems.
I think, truly poverty
and intergenerational
poverty is tragic. And we have
to separate that from
inequality because they're
conceptually different.
inequality, you know, taking a
snapshot of the country at
a particular time, were you
comparing this group of
40 40 million black people in
a freeze frame, to, you
know, over 100 million white
people, and looking at a
single number that describes
how they're doing, which
is just a mean. What that
doesn't capture is, for
example, the fact that this
generation of black Americans
is doing much, much, much
better than their parents.
So something like 70% of
black Americans report on
the Federal Reserve survey that
they're doing, that they're
better off financially than
their parents, which is
actually a higher percentage
than of whites who say
the same. Wow. So there's
two, there's two ways,
importantly, different ways to
look at this, you can
compare a group to itself at an
earlier point in time. And
if you do this with black
Americans, you know, huge
progress on health, you know,
rates of death, from cancer
going down life expectancy
going up. incarceration
rates, especially for black
Americans in their 20s have
more than cut in half since
I was in kindergarten.
Or you can you get a very
different picture. If you
compare two different groups
at the same time where
one group had had a massive
headstart in every way
imaginable. It could be the case
that both are making
rather fantastic progress, but
so long as one is ahead,
it will look like nothing's
changing, if you're only
looking at the gaps between
them rather than the Objective
Progress they're making.
So the
the racial issue in the United
States is often framed to in terms of
discrimination against blacks on the part
of Caucasians, and, let's say, the white
supremacy that has emerged as a
consequence of that, but that also seems
to fail as a hypothesis, given the
staggering success, let's say of Indian
Americans and of Asian Americans
in general, because if it was a, an issue
that was somehow related to the
Caucasian community, per se, you'd think
that we they would have been just as
efficient at holding back the progress
of those other groups as holding back
the progress of the black community.
Like Asian Americans aren't
even involved there. They're
doing really well. And we're
squabbling about race problems.
Yeah, it's strange that it does seem like
that I don't, I don't
really understand that.
Their success is an embarrassment to the
theory that white supremacy is crushing.
How do you For example, say what
what has been said about standardized test
scores, standardized tests, rather like
the a CT and a CT that they are, they are
created by Europeans for Europeans and
are culturally biased in very subtle ways
that,
you know, there's some hand
waving that's done here. But the
point is, the test is made by
white people for white people.
And then Asians come with no
particular background in European
culture, and destroy the white
people on this test right on
average. So that again, it's
an embarrassment to the theory
that all of society is tilted in
favor of whiteness. In subtle
and not so subtle ways, in a
lot of that with the Asians, a
lot of that does seem to be a
consequence of, of work habits. I
mean, I looked into
Asian versus Caucasian
performance in the US
a number of decades ago
for a federal government
project that I was
doing at the time. And
the Asians, this was the
children of first generation
Asian immigrants,
because the effect
seems to go away by about
three generations, maybe
because their Asians are
more thoroughly
enculturated into the American
community. But children,
the first generation,
Asian immigrants worked
hard enough so that that
served as the equivalent
to 15 additional IQ
points, which is roughly
the difference between
the typical State
University student and the
typical high school
student. Yep. So that's a
good example to have of a situation where
cultural differences
really seem to play a role.
Yes, and I've seen I've seen
data to that effect in the US
as well, which suggests
that just you know, it's not that
there's, there's a, what's
explaining it is a genetic difference.
It's that it's that, you know,
it's like more hours spent
studying on average, it's mom
and dad over the shoulder, you
know, making sure that you
do your homework and you do it,
right. That phenomenon is
not equally represented in every
culture, and it's underrepresented
among black Americans.
Well, that's, that'll be a statement
that'll definitely make you popular
again. So what do you what, what
makes you What? How do you know that?
Good question. Um, so
that we do have we do have
survey evidence, you
know, on self report surveys
of how, how much how
many hours per night?
students study. Brookings
has done work on this.
It's it's a, it's a taboo
subject. So I think
most academics
understandably, stay away from it.
We have extensive data
from Nielsen, which is
a one of the leading
market research firms and
of the famous Nielsen
television ratings, which
investigate everything
from what people spend
their money on to how
many hours of TV people
watch per day, and
breaks it down by race. And
you find big differences
in all of these things.
differences that are
consequential, if you are
concerned about closing
gaps in, say, wealth,
accrual, and income
and and all of these things.
So did will your book
contain solutions? I mean,
to these to these cultural
problems, just because
they're cultural doesn't
mean they're easy to
solve, obviously, right?
Any more than they would
be easy to solve if they
were a consequence of
prejudice, or biological
factors. But it isn't,
it isn't obvious how to
get from the situation
that you're describing
to, to somewhere better.
Yeah, you know, my book is, is for
adults. It's not, it's not, it's not for
children that want an easy solution to
everything. It's for people who recognize
the inherent trade offs and the complexity
in the world. And it's not to say
that there will be no solutions offered.
I think there are probably more clear
cut solutions to problems like problems
of policing and criminal justice than
education. But I do think incremental
progress is possible.
And I'm not, I'm not,
I'm not selling a solution. Really, I
think. I think, you know, many people
have just, understandably grown skeptical
of people who come and say, Oh, well,
I've got the solution. It's, it's simple.
I've done all the analysis. I know
everything that's wrong. And the solution
is simple. And it just requires us to
not be evil. Right? I think the world
is far too complicated and has far too
many trade offs for that. So the book
is about defending, defending a different
kind of anti racism to go against the
tide of the one that's currently sweeping
at least elite circles, in academia,
journalism, you know, Hollywood, corporate
america and so forth. Um, but it's
it's not it's not a you know, if you Want
to if you want a simple solution,
this is not going to be the book for you.
So you don't think
anti bias training based
on critical race theory is the answer.
So far, the evidence has not shown that
implicit bias trainings,
reduce any kind of
racism that we could
measure. And you know,
I think what it does do is it alienates a
lot of people. You know, I'm not I'm
not saying that there should be no kind of
diversity training
and in the context of a
workplace. But if the
if the the sum total of
the training is to tell people, you are
subconsciously racist
in ways that you can't
possibly, you know, by
definition, consciously
grab onto, and the solution is a kind
of Robyn D'Angelo esque
grovelling. You know,
there's, there's nothing to suggest that
that's the path forward for harmonious
relations between
people of different races.
I spoke with Chloe, Valerie
and she had worked. You
know, Chloe, Valerie,
probably she'd worked on a kind
of an anti racist, or
diversity, I guess you'd call
it course. And I looked
through her course. And it
was way more reasonable
than the like, part of the
problem with this anti bias
training. I've had friends
who go through it or if
they're working at Starbucks
or something, and it makes
people angry, to be to sit
there and be talked out
about how they're inherently
racist. Like, I feel
like it's more likely to I
don't know if there's any,
there probably aren't any
studies on this, but I
feel like it's more likely to
increase racism and
decrease it if you're just talking
at people about how
they're evil. I guide be mad
about it by just sit through
that for a couple of days,
especially if it was based
on Robyn D'Angelo stuff.
I mean, you know, I've
been in a classroom at
Columbia, where the professor
who happened to be white,
though, I think I would
have been angry either way,
said that all people of color
are victims of oppression.
And, you know, I wasn't I
was furious. I was furious
that she would characterize
it that that bluntly, and
that, broadly, I have to
imagine the experience of
being told that you are
by definition of racist, which
is what what Robyn
D'Angelo proposes in her in her
massively successful
bestselling book white fragility,
I have to imagine that
that's also it's a non starter
for many people. It's it's
Yeah, I don't think that,
you know, many of these
social justice inflected
bias trainings are inflected
with a kind of, kind of
dominance. And, you
know, it's a kind of so so for
instance, in the Angelo's
book, you know, the thrust of
the book is that if you're
talking to a black person
about race, and you're
white, you cannot disagree with
them. You can't do it.
It's immoral, it's unethical
to disagree with them about
anything related to race.
Right. So what what that
essentially sets up is a
completely unequal relationship.
And I know what people
will say, well, let's say
let's say in the broader
context of, you know, a
white supremacist culture, how
can you possibly say that?
You know, how can you
possibly complain about,
you know, white people being
mistreated in any context
and, you know, whatever
abstract ideas about, you
know, white supremacist culture,
you have can't possibly
justify a local explicit
dominance of one race by
another. How does that help
counter the alleged white
supremacist culture outside?
There's never any proposed
link, even between the two?
Well, and there is no
indication that those implicit bias
training programs have their
desired effect. I mean, it's not,
it's very difficult to design
psychological interventions that
produce positive effects.
And it's very difficult to do the
studies necessary to then
demonstrate that those effects exist.
And when you're dealing with
a phenomena that's only weakly
linked to racial attitudes,
which would be say, implicit bias
as measured by the Implicit
Association test that's only weakly
linked to actual behavior. And
then the training programs at
best have a weak effect if
it's not entirely negative. It's not
a solution to the problem that
we're discussing, although it
has the advantage of looking
like it's a solution. Which well,
which is often something
that's saleable, right? Something
that looks like a solution
that's actually implementable is
saleable, even if it doesn't have
an outcome, the outcome that's
desired because what is being
purchased isn't the outcome of
people purchasing it, like who knows it,
if they even care, they might just want to
look good, right,
it's a lot easier just to
look virtuous than to
actually be very well,
you could give them the benefit
of the doubt and say that they're
likely to be as virtuous, they're
as likely to be virtuous as the next
person, you know, but these are
very difficult problems. As, as Coleman
already pointed out, they're not
going to be solved simply. And if
you're a corporation that's pushed
to take noticeable action on problems
of race, the implicit bias training
programs at least offer you the
possibility of appearing state of
the art. And you might say, well,
you have a responsibility to assure
that what you're doing works. Yeah.
You do. Yeah.
And I think corporations can
afford to adopt a tragic vision
of human nature. like a like a
writer can. Corporations can't
throw their hands up and say,
Well, listen, we actually don't
know the honest truth is we do
not know how to take someone
who is biased, racially or
otherwise, and, and change their
fundamental, you know,
neural chemistry or personality or
whatever you want to call it
so as to make them less biased.
That is something our species
has not yet figured out. And
frankly, may never figure out
because we it's not just inevitable
that we will be able to fix,
you know, any any problem.
Of course, corporations can't
be seen it people mistake that
for callousness they mistake a
perhaps like a sober assessment
of what is possible and what's
not for not caring about the
underlying issue. And you
know, people in in whether they're
corporations or in academia
or otherwise, they lose face
if they can ever be construed
as not caring about an issue.
Yeah, yeah. Well, that's
partly why the implicit
bias training programs
have proved so popular, no, in
the absence of an
alternative solution that's easily
implementable. And, and
in keeping with the spirit of
the times, they dominate
the marketplace. And it's
probably not useful to be
too cynical about that. Even
though I think the tests, the
programs are reprehensible.
I understand why they're
being employed. Yeah,
a question I wanted to ask. So I can
sneak it in here. If you are, I guess,
mandated to take one of these diversity
trainer training or anti bias programs,
say, as an employee of somebody, and
you're not comfortable doing that, or it's
based on Robin de Angelo's work? Are
there suggestions you have for? For those
people? I threw up a couple of questions
on my Instagram, just asking people
if they had questions for you. And one
of the main ones was, as a student or as
a worker, how do you they use the term
fight back? But what do you do if you're
like stuck in one of those anti bias
things? Is there anything you can do?
I really, I really feel
for people. This is
another area where
I'm afraid I have to say, I
don't have a solution to
that problem. Yeah. All
I have is sympathy
with the problem itself to
be stuck in a scenario
where you are asked
to hold your tongue
when you have eminently
reasonable things to
say about the underlying
issue. But you know, that
the moment you open your
mouth, there is nothing
you can say, clear
enough or profound
enough to prevent you from
being labeled, you
know, a bigot or an Uncle
Tom or what have you.
And the reputational cost
you pay is likely to
outweigh you know, the
benefits of having, you
know, of having diversity
of opinion in the room
and it's so much easier
to just stay silent.
That's one way in which
the faulty information
is so harmful, right? Is is
once a false theory gets
instantiated and a false
treatment program. If you
question it, your reputation
is at stake. But if you
don't quit But it can never be
replaced by something that
might actually work. So, a
bad theory in that sense,
at least of this type is worse
than no theory at all.
Because standing up against
the bad theory appears to
make you a bad person. Yeah.
And ultimately, it's a
coordination problem. If there
were enough people to
stand up to it at the same
time, it wouldn't be a
problem. But there is a is
what what self censorship,
self censorship does? Is
it makes every person in
that implicit bias training,
who is having skeptical
thoughts in their mind
feel like they're the only
person in the room having
such thoughts? Yeah.
And they're not. They're not.
Right. Right.
That's why these kind of
conversations are important. That's why
would Coleman students important
to say, if you talk about some
con talk about topics, even you
remember, that black box thing
that happened on Instagram,
where everybody put a black box up,
which I thought was ridiculous,
but I woke up that morning, and
I looked at my phone, and
everyone had this black box up, and
I thought, Oh, my God, now I
have to put a black box up on
Instagram. And then I thought,
that is a ridiculous thought to have.
Now, as you have to know that
everyone is noticing who doesn't put
up the box where that's the most
crucial part about the black square.
Yeah, so it didn't end
up putting up a black
box. Because I had that
thought about No, now I
have to and thought, like,
No, I don't just blackbox
on Instagram is not
gonna make a difference,
anybody. But it is
hard when you get this.
Like, anyway, I didn't
put up the black box. And
then I had a whole
bunch of people messaged
me who had this black
box saying, Oh, I really
didn't want to, but I
did anyway. I know. At
some point, I mean,
it's different, I guess, if
you're gonna lose your
job. But if you don't talk,
if you don't speak out
about some things that
you think are wrong,
you corrupt your soul. Who
are you that and Isn't
that how entire societies
get totally screwed up?
Like, doesn't that can
that potentially screw
up? Entire societies?
Yes. It certainly it certainly
has that propensity across
time. Coleman, you're
standing up to this, like, how
is it that you're able to
manage that, practically and
philosophically, because
there's a practical side to it.
There's an uncanny valley
of that I have successfully
escaped, which means when
you come out as a heretic on
these issues. You you there's
a price to pay an immediate
price to pay that can last a
long time, in terms of your
reputation, reputation, your
friendships, your career and
so forth. You're Yes, your
mental health, no doubt. Your
family. And, but but on
the other side of that value,
Valley, if you're if you're, if
you're someone like me, which
obviously, you know, most
people most people aren't and
can't, can't be because of
circumstances. And you have a
podcast like I do, that's
grown a lot over the past six
months. And you know, I've
put myself in a position where I'm
successfully my own boss.
And I'm, I'm known as a heretic,
right? So I have I have nothing
to lose from further heresy
at this point, because I've
lost everything that I'm that
I'm going to lose. Which
makes it paradoxically easier,
right? You have to put yourself in a
position where you can sustain yourself
do it during that initial period of
loss, or you have to be fortunate
enough to be in that position.
And that that's not a situation that
characterized as many people. Correct.
So what do you hope your book will do?
Um, that's a good question.
I mean, I hope the book will
be persuasive to people
who are on the fence. I hope it
will give people who have
a gut level doubt about race
conscious anti racism, the
language to express where their
doubt might be coming from.
I hope it I hope it enlightens
and I hope, I hope people
get joy out of reading it. I
hope people learn something.
It helps me writing it helps
me clarify my own thoughts.
And I hope I really hope for it
to be a book that people
can read 20 and 30 years from
now, and it will it would no
hope. Hopefully some of the
issues in question will have
gotten better by then. But I
hope the book will still make
sense and resonate. Because
you know, this issue isn't
going away. And I hope to write
about it in a way that isn't
merely responding to, you
know, events of the past
six months, but he's actually
getting to philosophical
bedrock. On the issues in question.
Do you think things are going to
improve in the next couple of years?
In terms of the prevalence
of colorblindness
versus race consciousness? Yeah, just
the tensions that we're having now.
I mean, it's definitely gotten worse
than the last six months. So do you
see that? Do you continuing or think
that if Biden becomes president, which
seems to be a virtual certainty, that the
racial tensions that characterize the
United States are
actually going to decline?
So that's there, I think, two
countervailing trends. One
is, you know, the the the
problem of woke anti racism
precedes Trump. And isn't
is a is a, by and large a trend
that occurs independent
of who is or isn't in the White
House. So that will keep
that the engine of wokeness is
going to keep running. And
has seems to have only been
getting more powerful in
the past six years, especially.
On the other hand, I do
think that there were there are
lots of liberals and centrists
who, especially among
the elites, that were so
alarmed and appalled by Trump's
rhetoric and his, you know,
authoritarian tendencies. And,
you know, his his style
that they felt. They felt that
they couldn't, you know, given
the choice between criticizing
Trump and criticizing
the far left, they felt more
cautious, criticizing the far
left under a Trump presidency
than they might now under
Biden presidency. No, that's
an interesting, that's an
interesting idea. So you think a
Biden presidency might give
people the opportunity to liberal
people, let's say this opportunity
to separate themselves from
their more radical compatriots
say, within the Democratic Party,
it certainly offers that opportunity,
whether or not people take
it is anyone's guess, frankly,
and I wouldn't, I don't want to
signal too much optimism on
this score. But it's certainly an
opportunity given that Biden has
been fairly good in rejecting most
of the policy prescriptions
and sensibilities of the far left. I
think it would make sense for
people of influence to rally around
him as, as you know, a, a
president that hopefully will embody
actual liberal values rather
than a liberal social justice values.
I was I was hopeful about that. And
then Harris put her pronouns in her bio,
on Twitter. Seriously, I was like this,
you know, this actually, maybe this
isn't so bad. I think Biden might be
more center than he's putting on. You
know, given his past but then Harris
put her her pronouns in her Twitter.
I didn't know them. When he Yeah,
yeah. So that's, that's not good. Yeah.
He's funny. No, doesn't mean it.
Yeah, not
that that makes it a no, that
might even that might even be worse. Yeah,
I mean, isn't it I've what
I find to be strange is the
word though. I have an
obsession with this word, Latin x.
We have this word that's a bad one.
I have an obsession
with this word. I think
it's partly because as a kid, I grew up
around my Spanish speaking family members
on my mother's side
often. And, you know, by
the time I was at
lesson, I wasn't fluent.
But I had a, you know,
enough of a familiar
familiarity with the
language to communicate.
And when I got to Colombia, I heard this
word that I had never heard before. And
in all my days speaking to my Puerto Rican
family members, and it was sold as a word,
you know, the new polite term for Hispanic
Americans that, you
know, Hispanic Americans
are demanding, much
like the succession of
African American and
black from the earlier
Negro and colored
which used to be the polite
terms. Of course, it's
it couldn't be further
from the truth right. When pupae Hispanic
Americans about what they prefer to be
called, they find 95 96% say, Please don't
call call us Latin x,
either. I haven't heard
of that, or I've heard of it, and I don't
like it. And so the you know, so it's one
thing for there to be an elite bubble. How
could there not be
there's nothing inherently
wrong with that
everyone lives in a bubble.
But what what strikes me with particular
force is when the elite
are completely unaware
of how their peculiar, I should say, our
peculiar moral
sensibilities are not shared
by the general public, and therefore force
their sensibilities on the general public.
And there's nothing there's
almost nothing more philosophically
repugnant, almost
spiritually repugnant than the
attempt to force a particular
language usage. You know,
there's something about that
that's a deep violation of, of, of
individual freedom. It's not
obvious how language evolves
and how we all accept new
words, but to have them coined by
ideologues and then forced
into usage by moral threats, let's
say, there, there's, there's
something about that, that that's.
It irks you?
Yeah. irks? Me, too. I
yeah. I mean, that, yes.
It irks me very deeply.
It's an act of domination.
And but but it's an act
of domination that that
is all the more pernicious
for the fact that the
people doing the dominating,
often don't even know
it. Like, like, you know,
Elizabeth Warren, in her
presidential campaign
used the word Latinx. If you
think about it, from her
perspective, she should
be desperate to win over
the 95% of Hispanics, she
should be desperate not
to alienate them. Right,
she has every incentive
to and she still uses the
word Latinx. The question
is why? And you know,
I can only think it's
because the Hispanics in her
immediate circle, are all
themselves elites within
the bubble, who like
this word, right. So. So the
the bubble that is not
aware of itself ends up
imposing things on on
on everyone else, and just
alienating the pot. So
Kamala using putting her
pronouns in her bio is
is the example that that
made me think of this. I
mean, who are who are you?
What are you? Who are
you signaling to when you
do that? I think you're
signaling to my peers at
Columbia are gonna like
that. But is the democratic
base gonna like that? Hell
no. The Democratic base
and the wider country?
Of course not. What you're
signaling to what you're
saying is, I'm perfectly
perfectly fine, alienating.
You know, 70% of the
country say if it means
ingratiate, ingratiating,
myself to this particular
minority that has a lot
of cultural power and
sway right now. And that
sends that sends a very
bad signal. If democrats
keep doing that, they
should be very worried about
weakness. Do I think you
know, that it would seem to me to
be more logical in this early
stage of the new regime to
signal the ability to resist
that sort of temptation,
rather than the willingness
to be preemptively intimidated.
You think she's, maybe she's not even
intimidated? Maybe Maybe she is. But
maybe she's just surrounded by so
many people telling her that that's the
right thing to do that she believes
that, is that possible? I mean, her circle
might be a whole bunch of people
who all have their pronouns in their bio.
Mm hmm. No, I think
that that that is likely
true. And and who
knows, maybe they're trying
to play a split strategy
where Biden plays
to the middle and Kamala
appeases the woke,
bro.
But we'll see. Yeah, well, I hope, I hope
that things go well, I
mean, obviously, this
transition is a mess.
Yeah. I hope that the
vast majority of people
up here in Canada wish
everybody in the US
well, while they while
you go through this
convulsive process of, of
changing your government and that it's a
change for the better
that would be something
it should not be convulsive. I'm
personally embarrassed as an
American that a sitting
president is declaring victory. like
as if were a third world nation
that struggles with you No
authoritarian dictators come into
power. It's embarrassing to me.
Well, it is striking though
how close your elections
have been what for
the last four elections?
A country is so evenly
split down the middle
yet it's kind of miracle.
Or you could say the
parties just do a very
good job of competing with
one another, is another
way of thinking about it.
Yes, yes. Fair enough. And equally valid
way of thinking about it. Any idea when
your book is going to be finished? And,
and then also published, a depressingly
long time from now, so much so
that it's not worth dwelling upon?
Oh, well, that's good. It
gives you something important
to do, continually. And
they'll opportunity, as you said,
to, to clarify your thoughts.
There's nothing like
protracted writing to help you
manage that. Absolutely. Well,
that, that's usually when
I call time, as of about
an hour. If you want to
continue, we can continue.
But uh, I think we
should probably call it a
night, especially with
first podcast in two years.
Well, I think I think, oh, man, let
me say on behalf of, you know, out
of everyone that, you know, the
world is very glad to have you back.
Yes, well, I'm very glad to be back if
I am, in fact back, though. But it was
certainly a pleasure to be able to do
this tonight. And and, as I said, to see
you again, and to hear about what
you're up to, I hope that your endeavors
continue to breed success and that you
have the best of luck with your podcast.
Thank you very much. That podcast
is conversations with Coleman by the
way. You can subscribe to that on
all the normal channels and routes.
Where else can people find you can
find me on Twitter at cold
x man. You can find me at
Coleman hughes.org. And,
yep, those are my main avenues.
Well, thank you very much for coming on.
My pleasure.
Yeah, thanks a lot. Absolutely.